good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Tuesday I hope
everyone's having a fabulous day I know
I am hey checks how you learn I'm doing
good welcome back to the toast okay so I
wanted to kick off today's show with I
got like we got so many common questions
people
um had I did a little q a box on my
Instagram I just want to make sure
everyone is taken care of because we you
know launched a lot of big news
yesterday and you know me
um change averse girly and I guess we
have a lot of change averse girly
listeners as well so I really wanted to
answer some common questions people had
for us about what this means for the
toast and I can't stress enough like it
means nothing for the shows but like
let's you know what I mean it's really
change in name only nothing will change
about the way that Claudia and I do the
show the time that we do the show the
content in this show everything will be
the same if you missed yesterday's
episode aside from the artwork change
like you wouldn't notice anything has
changed right so here like the like the
couple most common questions people had
a lot of people wondered if our patreon
is changing at all no 7.99 a month five
extra episodes from your girls access to
the Facebook group patreon remains
unchanged patreon.com oh we have to
change our link we're waiting to get the
new URL for now it's patreon.com
morningtoast like I said Subway and
their cups there are so many things to
change there's so many things to change
um the second thing people had questions
on um and this was a fair question
seeing as how our podcast took so long
to come up on Apple and Spotify
yesterday is if we're still doing video
and audio yes we are
um the reason why our podcast took
forever we put it up at noon like we
always do but it didn't get up till like
four or five on Spotify and apple was
because we had our feeds changed because
we have a new feed with deer media
um the feeds have changed and moving
forward it'll be up a lot sooner we
apologize about that but that was
confusing for people because we had this
big announcement and then no podcast
right it's delayed as things move over
hopefully that ends with us soon yeah it
does
um the third thing a lot of people uh I
thought this was interesting because
people are always looking out for us you
know part of the reason why we um
started our own show is just for that
reason so that we could own our show and
nobody could cancel our show like the
morning breath and so a lot of people
thought like with the name change and
the deer media partnership it's because
like we don't own the morning toast so
we still own the copyright is all ours
the morning toast um we genuinely
changed the name because we felt like it
was time it had nothing to do with tier
media we still own our show completely
we own the trademark is our partner
yeah period uh the name change is
actually just coincidental that we all
announced it all on the same day the two
things were happening sort of at the
same time so we were like let's do it
all the same day big news not announce
one thing and then announce another
thing and everyone's saying like the
morning toast went to Deer media let's
just like use the correct verbiage yeah
and then the final thing um people had
questions on which was also a great
question is if we relinquish any
creative control when we entered into
our partnership with Jeremy media the
answer is no we say whatever we want we
are uncensored unhinged girlies and the
toast and the morning toast have that in
common nothing is going to change
creatively we're doing our show Monday
through Friday we're doing except
tomorrow we have to we haven't even
spoken about it on Friday we have we
haven't even spoken about we haven't
spoken about what is in store for us
tomorrow which is Yom Kippur
um and so while you guys might be upset
that there's no episode of the toast
like we're more upset because we're
going to be fasting and repenting
atoning not just like the hunger it's
also having to delve into what that
hunger represents what that hunger
represents and who you are and who you
want to be and everything that you did
wrong in the last year and
what you want to do better for the next
year it's a lot of emotional work I know
and I feel like us not talking about it
is really representative of like me I've
been like pushing it out of my brain
like I've been really ignoring it but it
is tomorrow it is the the one day a year
I probably dread the most
um and I'm glad that it's here because
that means it's almost over
yeah but yeah yeah I'm I'm not looking
forward to it
neither but
we must go through it we do it every
year so
I mean I think this year is actually
going to be my hardest year yet because
one loophole to Yom Kippur is like
sleeping in the later you sleep the less
you have to fast I'm up at seven like
it's gonna be the longest fast of my
life
so we shall see how that goes then we
will be back on Thursday for regular
toast but then Friday there's no show
because Claudia is traveling for the end
log tour and I am heading to Atlanta for
a spritz meet and greet so no show no
show can't wait to see you guys in
Pittsburgh sold out and I did my sports
meet and greet last night it was just
fabulous because one it was fabulous and
two because like everyone there was like
on a high they were like they had so
many questions about the Rebrand and
they were like congrats it was really
like a celebratory meet and greet That's
so exciting it was really fun any
highlights any gifts that you got
anything for somebody brought me a 10
piece nugget which was literally so nice
because it ended up we were gonna like
go early and eat but it took us two
hours with traffic so I ended up showing
up like eight minutes late
um and I was so hungry and towards the
end this queen like Queen showed up with
a big bag from McDonald's and a soda and
I was shoving my face I was so hungry
that was the highlight of the main grade
that is a highlight period period it was
so good I [ __ ] love McDonald's I'm so
glad while you were doing that I was
recording the new episode of the
redheads with the girlies recapping
lessons in chemistry our book of the
month and it was just another wonderful
episode of like the most wonderful
podcast
after the toast like and it was another
great day of being a redhead it was
another great day of being a redhead the
redheads is just such a wonderful
Community we're growing you know
exponentially every day so I think a lot
of you now are part of the community and
we're so happy to have you and it's just
a monthly reminder of literature
literature and the joys of literature
there were a couple girlies last night
who brought me their Kindles to sign
that's the new thing it's literally the
highest honor it's the highest honor
especially when they have you sign the
Kindle not the case and
um they actually requested that Ben not
sign it since he doesn't support
literate women and I was really proud of
them for taking a stand I think that's
so important
been nowhere they stand but I think Ben
had like the best time at the meet and
greet because like when it's me and Ben
a lot of times like I think people
forget
that Ben is there
um but this is the first meet and greet
we've done since Ben launched his
podcast good guys with Josh Peck and so
many people came up especially like a
lot of people's husbands and boyfriends
they were like I love good guys it's so
good Josh and you are the best and I
think Ben was like really excited to see
the feedback from his podcast like I
could tell he had like a little glimmer
in his eye
that's really cute it was really cute it
was a great meet and greet Long Island
is stunning it is don't we where in Long
Island was it Westbury it's like really
nice me and Ben at one point looked at
each other and we were like what if we
just moved to Long Island
and I'm actually so down going back to
my roots but
um it's literally the most expensive
place to live in the country and it has
the highest real estate tax and I'm just
not down
yeah so it was like a flash in the pan
idea yeah been there already rolled that
out right
um so yeah it's just fabulous day it's
raining here in New York missing you
dearly how's worldini thinking about me
obviously always thinking about you the
weather here has turned gorgeous it's so
nice and just like literally perfect
weather like a little chilly
it's like Zach keeps saying it's LA
weather you know where it's just like
perfect not hot yeah not cold
oh yesterday was also literally anything
yesterday was also a fabulous day
because Jackie and I believe we have
decided what we're gonna be for
toastaween this year
um and I'm really excited about it yep
we gotta start ordering and we can start
rehearsing separately of course yeah I
gotta start practicing like you know the
dialogue I don't want to give anything
away but
theorizing the character the character
and how I'm going to interpret the
character because I'm not an actress
whatsoever but no don't say that there's
one day a year where I give the theater
my all and that is on the toastoween
episode and I leave it all there I have
nothing else for the rest of the year
because I've given all of my acting
chops to that episode and I intend to do
it again what's exciting is that we're
going to be together for toast to Bean
I'm flying down to Florida so we'll be
Flamingo girlies for toastoween because
the next week is your 30th birthday it
was his 30th birthday
um so we'll have toastoween and Jackie O
B day all in one week the patreon's
gonna be popping off yeah I'm excited
for you to come down here the flamingos
are so gorgeous and they're so
underrepresented on this show right now
I match them today maybe I'll take a
picture in front of them to let them
know that I see you and I appreciate you
and I'll be back for you
yeah yeah I mean we've otherwise got a
great show lots of unique news lots of
people who need to be made fun of yeah
um yep yep yep those are my favorite
types of shows like when people just
need to be put in their place and I'm
gonna be the one to do it Lena Dunham
Billy Eichner yeah they're wild in and
that's something I never thought I would
say because one thing about me is I love
Billy Eichner I mean he gave me my start
in television
and for those who don't know I was on an
episode of Billy on the Street when I
was in college and I looked fugly and
Billy made fun of my outfit
um but I like I have a deep like
deep-rooted respect and admiration
honestly for Billy Eichner like anything
he's in I just love
um and I'm gonna have to drag him today
so that'll be exciting yeah you gotta do
what needs to be done so I think without
further uh do
tell me how this sounds
here are the fast don't press the button
yet like we're just spitballing okay
okay without further did it did it do
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of the toast
like I just think we don't really need
to change it just our Rhythm needs to
change okay but just the wake up still
connotes morning okay but like in our
defense we did just wake up like it's
early as [ __ ] and a lot of people were
like are you guys still gonna say good
morning Millennial I was like yeah [ __ ]
I woke up and I'm doing the toast we're
still doing at the same time let me the
first time in the day that I'm talking
to Claudia so I would say good morning
to my sister yeah I'm still saying good
morning you know what you don't have to
follow every rule do you know what I
mean yeah
so uh we got a lot of helpful sound off
in the comments yesterday on YouTube you
did but I didn't see anything that was
the one okay here's what people
suggested without further Ado here's a
toast to the fast five stories that you
need to know
that I like okay
here's another one but that one doesn't
leave room for crunch without further
Ado to do it's time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
pour a glass and raise a toast I'm not
crazy about that one but everyone was
loving it in the comments so that's
important to note
I feel like the one that I did at the
beginning was like good like I think we
might be overthinking like the reason I
like hear the past five stories that you
need to know
but what about the crunch sound I know
well the crunch we could just do it and
it will be like for the for the OG
listeners and then like in a year from
now when people discover us on Tick Tock
they'll be like does any pets know why
they use that bite sound and a little
heart back to our roots
so you want to do what here are the past
size stories that you need to know
okay and I want to do here are the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your toast
sound off in the comments which one is
better let's hit the crunch for all
time's sake hit the quench actually what
if we just said without further Ado hit
the crunch
that's okay
I think the first two that we just
brainstormed are better Okay cool so um
let's get into it yeah today's episode
of the toast
is brought to you by the Clinique Even
Better clinical dark spot interrupter if
you have dark spots it can often feel
like a vicious cycle as soon as one
Fades another one pops up girls who have
dark spots know it's the bane of your
existence your cross to bear on this
planet I get them really bad in the
summer or when I'm exposed to a lot of
sun like on vacation and for a while I
just thought like there were things that
you lived with I didn't know that there
was products you could purchase that
would change your life but you could
break the cycle with the Clinique Even
Better clinical dark spot interrupter
it's a powerful serum that works on
melon and Rich all the way up to fair
skin it helps physically correct dark
spots like acne marks and it can protect
from future discoloration so it's not
even enough that you're getting rid of
these annoying ugly dark spots but
you're also preventing future dark spots
from popping up on your face and that's
just really so valuable I can't put a
price on the value it's like that
MasterCard commercial Priceless those
were great commercials so here's a
little bit of interesting factoids about
the serum 94 of people demonstrated an
improvement in radiance invisible skin
tone like acne marks in just eight weeks
they saw a 39 visible reduction 39
visible reduction in dark spots in 12
weeks they also have a damage eraser
brightening complex it is more
concentrated it has boosted technology
to deliver dramatic brightening results
but it's also gentle enough for all skin
types so you can trust this brand
because Clinique is just a brand that
you know and trust that's been around
forever I feel like you know our
grandmother's used it and people are
still using it today because it's just
that good it is um
proven that in just two and a half hours
it can quell redness from any irritation
that can trigger new visible spots and
worsen the existing ones it is
powerfully brightening and again it
works from melon and Rich skin to fair
skin it can help improve uneven tone and
interrupt the look of future dark spots
so you can get the even better clinical
dark spot interrupter today it's
available at clinique.com Clinique is
spelled
c-l-i-n-i-q-u-e.com and that product is
called the even better clinical dark
spot interrupter fabulous for dark spots
and then while you're on the website you
can just shop some of the fabulous like
skincare Glam from Clinique because once
you're on the website I just feel like
once you're on the website right that's
Clinique once you're on the website once
you're on their website enjoy the
website no once you're the website like
what are you doing like you know you're
gonna pay for shipping so you might as
well get a bunch of stuff
today's episode is also brought to you
uh by Legacy box okay this is by far
like the brand I get the most DMS about
like what was that company what was the
code write it down girlies because even
if you don't want to send in your legacy
box now you can buy it now and use our
discount and then when you're ready
you've got all your camcorder vhs's up
from the basement then you can send it
in but don't miss out on the discount so
Legacy box is a fabulous digitizing
service where you can send old Home
Videos home photos like if you grew up
in the VHS era the camcorder era
whatever you have sitting in a box that
you want to access Legacy box is going
to digitize it for you in a really safe
and streamlined way you can save time
and money that your family invested in
capturing family vacations all things
like that with Legacy box
so we are VHS girlies I feel like for
years we had just bins of VHS and like
camcorders in our storage unit and once
a year we would like try and get it and
we would like buy something from Best
Buy that like broke the camcorder Legacy
box is amazing throw all your crap in
there and they'll do all the rest for
you they even send you a label like
there's literally nothing required of
you they'll send you emails along the
way being like hey girlie
um your stuff just arrived hey girly
here's what we're up to now they'll send
you a ton of emails so you feel like
safe because you know handing over that
box of camcorders is kind of like
handing over a part of your soul and
you're worried about it you know and
they're going to keep you abreast it's
like daycare you know they're gonna keep
you abreast on what your child is up to
and you owe it to your family to
safeguard your memories
um don't let your photos continue to
fade also obviously this is a great
thing but it's also such a nice gift for
like a grandma or a parent
um because I feel like it's like really
sentimental and really emotional and
these are memories if that's like the
one thing about technology like your
memory is like fade because the
technology Fades like we're moving on
every day thumb drives Cloud everything
so it's a really good gift to get to
have one for an anniversary a birthday
Father's Day Mother's Day
um so use our code Christmas is coming
up use our code and send it in when
you're ready it's legacybox.com toast
for an exclusive offer
legacybox.com toast become the hero of
your family and everyone's gonna like be
obsessed with you
um and save the memories before it's too
late buy a legacy box today
legacybox.com toast for our exclusive
offer legacybox.com toast
great thank you you're welcome
our first for all the waves and all the
storms in the sea I'm I really never
want to learn the words after that you
know I think we should make up our own
because you say you gotta welcome when
you do the ad so what can I say except
yeah welcome for all the links and all
the codes that'll save
that's good yeah that's good attitude
and I had like a sexy like you know like
jazz bar tone to my voice you did I can
confirm I can confirm okay first story
Billy Eichner blames straight people for
the Dismal opening of his gay rom-com
Bros it's just it's just so unoriginal
you know blaming the straights okay just
listen to for everyone listening just
listen to all the tweets that were
issued and then the retorts because
they're [ __ ] funny Billy Eichner has
complained that straight people quote
just didn't show up to his new gay
romantic comedy after it bombed at the
box office on opening weekend Bros which
is produced by Judd Apatow and
reportedly cost 22 million dollars to
make garnered Buzz for being the first
gay romantic comedy from a major Studio
but it brought in a paltry 4.8 million
dollars since its release Friday Eichner
who's the movie's lead star and
co-writer took to Twitter to express his
disappointment over the dire numbers
with a controversial take that quickly
garnered backlash quote this is from his
Twitter last night I snuck in and sat in
the back of a sold out theater playing
Bros in La how convenient that it was
sold out no but it's like but it tanged
so right someone sold out theater
um something's not adding up here the
audience howled with laughter to start
to finish burst into Applause at the
very end and some were wiping away tears
as they walked out it was truly magical
really I am very proud of this movie
Rolling Stone already has Bros on the
list of the best comedies of the 21st
century what's also true is that at one
point a theater chain called Universal
the studio behind the movie and said
they were pulling the trailer because of
the gay content Universal convinced them
not to America [ __ ] yeah etc etc then he
said quote that's just the world we live
in unfortunately even with glowing
reviews great Rotten Tomato scores and a
cinema score Etc straight people
especially in certain parts of the
country just didn't show up for Bros and
that's disappointing but it is what it
is he subsequently implored that
everyone who isn't a homophobic weirdo
go to a cinema to see Bros as soon as
possible however the comedian was
quickly blasted by gay and straight
Twitter users alike many of whom accused
him of shaming people for not seeing his
movie quote see my movie or you're a
homophobe is a hell of a marketing [ __ ]
no it's a lot it's a Latin also at four
point million 4.8 million dollars in
sales like also gay people didn't show
up for you okay so for me like it's very
layered uh personally I think I'm like
the furthest thing from a homophobe and
I didn't see the movie and that's mostly
because like times have changed like I
don't really go like I really want to
see don't worry darling too and I still
haven't seen it it took me six months to
see Top Gun like people are just
changing because of kovid so that's just
super important to acknowledge
um I think it's also important to
acknowledge and this is coming from
someone who really like and I mean this
honestly like I love Billy Eichner I've
never disliked anything he's been in
like I follow him I followed him for a
really long time I don't know if he's
necessarily a leading man that's what
I'll say and the third thing is and this
is something I just I was reading a lot
of people's responses watching a lot of
tick tocks from the gay community I
don't think that Billy Eichner is like
extremely well liked
by the gay community I don't think they
consider him like a likable leading man
um and I think that might have a lot to
do with it and I also think it's really
important this is why I feel mostly like
his
retort is unfair because so much of the
marketing I saw for the movie was like
in Niche area so like they were really
targeting obviously it's a movie about
two gay guys they were targeting with
their marketing the gay community so to
like put so much money and time
investing in like marketing towards the
gay community and then blaming the
straight Community for not showing up
well we weren't marketing towards right
also I did see a few commercials for the
movie and I like
it didn't look good sorry I didn't see a
funny joke I don't really know what the
movie's about like it was they weren't
good trailers sometimes you see a movie
trailer and the movie looks amazing and
actually the movie is quite bad there's
an art to trailer making we all saw the
holiday like that was her full-time job
and I actually thought that these
trailers like it seemed actually low
budget that they couldn't get a better
trailer knowing now that this is Judd
Apatow and it's 22 million dollars is
really shocking I also want to say one
gay critic hit back at Eichner saying
Bros bombing at the box office is a
failure of ego Billy Eichner is a b-list
star not a leading man and nobody is
going to theaters to watch a random
rom-com in 2022. that's [ __ ] true no
oh my God that's straight back straight
facts for Billy to assume it would be a
blockbuster just because he's gay and
funny is pure Hollywood narcissism many
other people added that films about gay
men including the birdcage and Brokeback
Mountain performed strongly at the box
office and insisted that Bros simply
didn't look like an enjoyable movie yeah
no that that has to be said you know it
has to be said because I think there's
and don't get me wrong like there's not
enough there should be tons of rom-coms
and I feel like streaming is the perfect
place to have a ROM because to have
rom-coms because rom-com's like all
right what what they used to be like
people are not getting up and going to
the theater I mean it took me six months
to go to Top Gun and Top Gun was this
like major you know motion picture
you know what it was it was a movie that
felt like felt like a movie movie and I
feel like this is a movie that feels
like I should be watching on a streaming
service yes this is a movie that would
have done really well it comes Netflix
so many like to go to the theater like
you really need to see a movie that's a
real movie it's like a big production
it's theatrical it's got music it's got
action scene on a big screen because
there's so much happening right and
that's why I think Top Gun was really
like a movie that felt like a movie
because it had all of that tuna
no I won't let go of my hand like there
was all this like involvement from like
marketing and music and action and stars
like and you know what I know it's like
really mean but it's it's fine because
it came from a gay movie critic like
that was that was facts like a B list
he's not a leading man just to blame it
on the street yeah no no lie to blame it
on the straight is like kind of
low-hanging fruit for just the movie not
being compelling
that one tweet see my movie or you're a
homophobe is a hell of a marketing pitch
yeah it was just like it was a lot Billy
like yeah it's it's and you know what it
is kind of spam all the time and there's
maybe not like a reason like one direct
reason I mean obviously like him saying
that you know a chain of theaters wanted
to remove it because it was gay like
that's problematic but I don't really
feel like that's pertinent to the
conversation yeah I also feel like I'm
looking at Judd Apatow's filmography now
because I want to see what the last
movie he made was I feel like it was I
feel pretty
all right so good so good so good and
did I see that in theaters I did
I think I did because I was so excited
yeah me too
um also yeah his last couple of movies
were like but that was it on a streamer
right and it was kind of a flop I just
feel like that era of people going to
the movies for Judd Apatow yes his past
not to turn up it's not talented and I
don't want to watch his movies but I
don't know that I'm gonna go to the
movies for them going to the movies now
is a much bigger production it's an
affair today than it used to Bay yeah no
you're completely right and like the
really cute funny Judd Apatow movies
like are meant to be watched at home and
the big theatrical don't worry darling
with all that press the Top Guns it is
meant for the theater not every movie is
meant for the theaters now we've we've
changed as as human beings like our
behaviors from covid have changed we got
used to everything just like showing up
on our doorsteps we're very entitled and
I used to be like a big moviegoer and
I've been since coveted ended like
once to see Top Gun once not every movie
is meant for the theaters and this is a
perfect movie
because I think Fire Island the gay
rom-com on Hulu did very well oh Hulu's
been killing it they had like their
first like gay Hallmark Vibe Holiday
Movie killed it so ROM Kami like not
serious kind of you know silly movies
are not meant for the theater anymore
and I think that it would be hoove
Studios to understand that because they
could have went with a direct release
buy it on iTunes that had like a
fabulous opening weekend yeah all the
straights and all the gays would have
cuddled up on Friday night with a bowl
of popcorn in their living rooms
to watch
why you gotta be gay
what's that
well he says why you got to be black
like whenever someone's wearing a black
dress he's like well why is it got to be
black like it's really funny
um and now I'm just like you know
appropriating that language I'm sorry
um our next story is someone else who's
being dragged to filth dragged down
Fifth Avenue she wishes uh Lena Dunham's
saland
has been slammed for saying she wants
her casket driven in the pride parade so
she tweeted when I go I want my casket
to be driven through the New York City
pride parade with a plaque that reads
she wasn't for everyone but she was for
us who can arrange she asked get in line
Lena okay we all want that several
angered Twitter users flooded the post
with messages of confusion and criticism
over her wish one member said girl no we
do not claim you like that a third
shaded the actress for centering herself
over marginalized folks even in death
she said so I wouldn't expect anything
better from you that's so true because
the way that I was thinking it it's like
I'm sure the gay community is like
please like leave us out of this like
we've been through enough we don't need
Lena Dunham now too
um but then also she's right like
centering her death around like in a
press group like pride is about
celebrating all the oppression that the
gay can be like yeah way to make it
about you Lita yeah and maybe if someone
else tweeted this verbatim like it would
have been totally celebrated okay who is
someone who could say this like Mariah
Carey yeah like someone who is somebody
who's actually beloved by the community
right right it's not a good week for the
gays everyone is coming for them right
and I also feel like for Lena Dunham
she always she constantly thinks she's
like doing something and saying
something in every which way she turns
it's like no no you know what happened I
mean there's we could I could write a
dissertation on like the rise and fall
of Lena Dunham for me the fall had
everything to do with that um article
she wrote about her Jewish boyfriend
being like a dog
um but I don't think that was the
downfall for everyone I think everyone
came to it in their own way but I think
a lot of it had to do with the success
of girls and like Lena Dunham being
touted as the voice of Her generation
and I think she like really believed
that when people told her that and she
got to a place where she thought she
could do or say anything and people
would think it was like [ __ ] prolific
um however it was not like I think she
sent this tweet and she was like type
type oh this is gonna kill send yeah and
she just she hasn't learned yet that
like the time where Lena Dunham could
like fart and people would think it was
beautiful that time is so over
it was short-lived and it's over and she
has to stop I feel like she's gotten
that message because it's been like so
rough reiterated yeah it's been like
she's but every time she tries to
resurface like she steps again and I I
know what the the downfall was forever
Junior oh no it was her book when she
like admitted to like molestation yeah
it was really graphic and really
disturbing
um and she also made light of it
completely what's the Odell Beckham Jr
thing so she had claimed um in her
newsletter with Lenny letter that um
Odell Beckham Jr ignored her because she
wasn't hot enough in her tuxedo she said
I was sitting next to Odell Beckham Jr
and it was so amazing because it was
like he looked at me and he determined I
was not the shape of a Woman by his
standards he was like that's a
marshmallow that's a child that's a dog
it wasn't mean he just seemed very
confused the vibe was very much like do
I want to [ __ ] it is it wearing a yep
it's wearing a tuxedo I'm going back to
my cell phone then she had to issue an
apology to him yeah
way to jump to conclusions yeah maybe he
just thought you were [ __ ] annoying
and he didn't want to talk to you or you
know maybe he was tired yeah no the
whole Jesus Christ this idea that men
don't want to engage in conversations
with her because they don't want to [ __ ]
her like no but not even that like for
me it would be like you literally don't
know this man did he say anything to you
no so you're just assuming he's
dismissive of you completely because
he's so shallow like that's [ __ ] rude
if somebody ever assumed anything even
remotely like that about me and I didn't
even say anything right right she said
in her apology that she projected her
insecurity clearly into the situation
and made these assumptions clearly
clearly no I think it was really the
book thing that like did it for everyone
I think it was a series of things and I
think for different people different
things really bothered them and affected
them I think for you obviously the
Jewish dog thing I think for the most of
America they don't really care about um
instances of anti-Semitism I think for a
lot of people it's this Odell Beckham Jr
thing and I think for a lot of people it
was the book
comments what did Lena Dunham do to you
I don't know sound off in the comments
raise your hands if you've been
personally victimized by Lena Dunham
also I think for a lot of people it was
the show Girls I think the first season
was really great and revolutionary yeah
but then I think the later Seasons there
was a lot that that didn't need to be in
there yeah maybe people didn't like it
especially people who loved the first
season which was most people yeah no I
watched it all um through and through
and I think a lot of people still love
it like I think a lot of people watch it
as their comfort show I watched it once
and like I never really needed to get
back to it because everyone was the
[ __ ] worst in that show except for
shoshana
um
where is it going with that thought I'm
not sure but all in all like Lena Dunham
needs and by the way I think she knows
this the situation that she's in because
she really hasn't done any front-facing
work
camera in front of the camera work in
many many years everything I've ever
seen her do she's like a writer on she's
a creator of she's director she uses her
talents and she is talented for sure
um in a non-public-facing way because I
think she knows she's become like so
polarizing yeah so that's good at least
she's self-aware that's good you were
watching something that was written by
her and yes industry me and Ben watch
the first episode and when we were done
the first thing was written by Lena
Dunham and we were like
we just talked about that Jennifer
Lawrence Vogue cover that had an essay
by Lena Dunham oh yeah she does like she
doesn't like she wrote the review on the
cover of um
Jeanette mccurdia's book yes she did so
she's a writer girl she's a writer girl
she's very behind the scenes now and I
think that's best for for a while we we
still need to break it it hasn't been
enough time
I don't know if it ever will be yeah are
you ready for our next story
is it then oh yeah I'm ready oh no uh
yeah I'm ready okay cool germaphobe
Howard Stern leaves his bunker to dine
with Pals for the first time since 2020.
um Infamous germaphobe and coveted
fearing Howard Stern who has been
broadcasting from home since March 2020.
oh my God still yeah went out to dinner
for the first time since the start of
the pandemic he dined at the Israeli
restaurant laser wolf in Williamsburg on
Saturday night with a host of stars
including Jennifer Aniston close friend
Jimmy Kimmel Jon Hamm Justin Thoreau and
Jason Bateman a fellow Diner snapped the
photo and sent it to dumois where we all
can see it
um I saw this on dumois and I was like
living for one this group of people too
them eating at this like Israeli kosher
style restaurant in Brooklyn that's
popping off Ben went he said it was
amazing I mean it must have been amazing
to get Howard Stern out of his house for
the first time and all the way to
Brooklyn three years all the way in
Brooklyn he said on his show that he had
a really exhausting weekend emotionally
and physically for the first time in two
years I ventured out of the house he
said it was too much for me it was too
much I haven't been out in two years uh
he said that Jimmy Kimmel invited him to
this dinner and with his wife and his
wife was excited and wanted to go Howard
was skeptical he said I said to myself I
don't want to go I'm in a panic I don't
want to get covered
eek I feel like this is like um
how agoraphobia starts yeah I
obviously it's an enormous privilege to
be able to like work from home
completely literally not leave your
house for three years for groceries
about like working from home yeah it's
all of the services that are being
brought to you you have a doctor all the
people that have to leave their house
and work in order for you to have those
things right no it's it's extremely
privileged and it's kind of like crazy
and I feel like he might be like
struggling like this is how you slip
into full-blown agoraphobia like afraid
of leaving your home yeah and obviously
there are degrees to germaphobia I think
he's his is very extreme but I do feel
like his show and his persona for so
many years has been like you know he's a
man of the people he's so relatable yeah
yeah I can't imagine his listeners are
hearing this and are
team Howard no because you know a lot of
people they listen to him in the car on
their way to work truck drivers who are
responsible for the supply chain who
literally kept us all alive during covet
it's and by the way he's totally
entitled to be feeling nervous whatever
but like to broadcast it it's like a
little out of touch yeah I I think this
reads as pretty privileged yeah and then
like the one time he leaves it's like
dinner with Jimmy Kimmel and Jennifer
Aniston and it's like that's just not
been his brand no he's really like blue
collar guy everyone loves him and the
people relatable people but I don't
think anybody can relate to this I can't
imagine there are that many people in
this country who actually have not have
had the privilege to not leave their
house in the last three years and today
for the first time dining with Jennifer
Aniston and I think a lot of the people
who are still hunkered down or hunker
down for a reason like they are
autoimmune they have diseases that like
actually put them even more at risk and
even those people have to leave their
house because they have to work they
have to grocery shop like not everything
can come to them it's extremely
privileged and it's it's giving a little
yikes and that pains me to say because I
love Howard Stern he's like one of our
biggest Role Models I feel like Howard
has been kind of yikes in the last few
years like I feel like we've reported a
few stories on him where it's just like
there was something a few weeks ago
about Howard what do you do because I
did something he was against someone oh
the queen
um
like so it's giving yikes it's giving
yikes that's so crazy yeah I can't
believe he's been doing his show from
home I had no idea
yeah especially because like he does his
show in a big studio and Robin is in a
separate room like also what about the
guests are they coming to his house no
I'm sure they're all remote
that's great that the show is like the
quality hasn't changed and obviously
well he's the biggest show at the
biggest radio network they're gonna find
a way to make him premium content
wherever he is right and you can
obviously have a home studio when The
Show Goes On I'm saying for everything
outside of work I also feel like this
type of like paranoia can lead to
trouble in a marriage because it sounds
like Beth was like let's please go to
dinner get me out of this house and he's
like still so afraid and I feel like
um
you know it's no way to live really
she's also much younger she's very
social she's fabulous she does a lot of
work with Charity like she's gotta go
she's got to leave the house and if they
can't leave the house together I feel
like that's you know could potentially
have negative impacts on the marriage
which would be terrible
yeah I feel that
so that's like a weird Flex from Howard
weird Flex news of the day yeah I agree
next up are you ready for our next story
now you're not ready no no I'm not ready
because this is the next story that's
brought to you by fashion pass
yes
we know so many times toasters already
know about fashion pass already use
fashion pass because it is truly the
steeniest clothing rental service you
will get unlimited rentals for one flat
price what sets apart fashion pass from
all the other turnt clothing renting
Services is the fact that they're closer
queued they're not ugly frocks that your
grandma would wear they are stylish they
are hot and there's stuff that's
available like on revolve right now so
you're really getting a amazing value
for stunning clothing that you actually
want to be seen in they have so much
you'll save so much money because you're
not buying clothes all the time clothing
rental is a much more sustainable way of
shopping it's a much more financially
responsible way of shopping and it's
just a great way to refresh your
wardrobe multiple times a month without
spending as much money it's really smart
and they have the best brands for love
and lemons hello show me your moo moo my
sweatshirt sweatshirt Romper Today show
me girls we're moving I wouldn't be
surprised if it's available right now
because I just got it so they have like
really cool brands that are hot right
now available for rental if you hate
spending 200 on an outfit that you're
gonna wear one time or like take a photo
in and then basically you can never wear
again clothing rental might be for you
Jackie and I both use fashion pass we're
both on the trendsetter plan which
basically means you can pick three
clothing items and two accessories every
order and you can switch out your order
as many times a month as you want so you
don't have to wait for the whole month
to be over before you can return it
you're done with it you're done send it
again get new stuff as many times a
month as you want
um shipping is super fast they take care
of everything they dry clean it so you
don't have to worry about doing that and
then you know when you get something it
has already been dry cleaned
you just send it back in the pre-labeled
bag they give you and you get to choose
new items it couldn't be easier and one
of the best parts is that if you find
something on fashion pass that you just
love like you can't live without you're
obsessed you can buy it directly from
them and buying directly from them saves
you so much money you get a huge
discount anywhere from 30 to 60 off it
is a better way of shopping constantly
and of course it's sustainable if you're
not into renting and you just want to
purchase something you can actually buy
directly from their website now even if
you're not a member they offer free
shipping and returns it's super easy and
you can purchase brand new items
or like new items for huge discounts up
to 70 off which is amazing we actually
have a special discount code for you
guys today if you go to fashionpass.com
use code toast at checkout you'll get 40
off your first month so you could try it
for just 39 that's unlimited rentals for
just 39 with code toast
great thank you so much I actually just
was looking up while you're reading that
I was on fashion pass and I was looking
at show me your MooMoo rompers and
there's a bunch that I need to go and
rent because I'm loving my Romper today
I have like there's a piece of debris
under my leggings I'm not sure if it's
translating to the camera but it's
gorgeous there is a piece of debris
stuck to the inside of my leggings I
look like I'm fingering myself over
YouTube there's jabri what was what do
we keep shrapnel shrapnel oh I got it
it's like a piece of glue stuck ah
sorry you can continue don't mind me I'm
just like picking up my vagina okay
because our next story is some book
celebrity Memoir by Khan
making
before reserve your judgment because she
is making a lot of Revelations in her
newest book
um and pulling back the curtain in her
new Memoir making a scene in the book
it's called making a scene it's called
making a scene that's a good one she
offers her thoughts about rising to fame
as one of the stars of ABC's fresh off
the boat she puts forth allegations of
rape and onset sexual harassment the
rape before
um before she was on the show and onset
of fresh off the boat sexual harassment
allegations and she's reflected on what
motherhood means for her career so she
is revealing a lot in this book
including that she was sexually
assaulted before finding Fame she also
claims a male producer harassed her on
the set of fresh off the boat and she
talks about her attempted suicide
attempt after the backlash she received
following fresh off the boat's renewal I
remember many years ago she had tweeted
that fresh off the boat was renewed and
she was wrote on Twitter that she was
really upset and she was like crying
that it was renewed and I think a lot of
people were thought she was a grateful
ungrateful
Etc and she said that it her into such a
depression she um contemplated suicide I
mean when the internet comes for you
absolutely nobody and nothing can
prepare you for what that's like for
your mental health so I totally believe
that
um I think a book is actually great for
Constance Wu because she had this really
weird moment where she blew up not even
so much from fresh off the boat from
crazy Rich Asians and then Hustlers so
it was this kind of unprecedented
success and then just it came out that
she was you know allegedly a monster and
terrible to work with and really mean
um and the internet did its thing you
know drove her to complete Madness
contemplating suicide and she really has
not been heard from for a very long time
and yesterday actually I saw Tick Tock
she's in a new I think it's like a kids
movie
what she's about the alligator oh she's
also in a new Amazon Prime show the
terminalist oh um she's in this this new
movie it's like about this young cartoon
boy who has like a best friend that's a
crocodile and he's trying to de-stigma
like crocodiles are nice like they're
not mean and Shawn Mendes like I think
has a song in it and then she was doing
press with Shawn Mendes and she looked
extremely Smitten by him I mean who
wouldn't
um so she's been like popping up in my
life recently when she's been really
M.I.A for a long time so I guess the
book coming out with this new Resurgence
of work makes a lot of sense and I'm
extremely open to reading this I think
everyone deserves a second chance like
let's not you know forget what she did
wasn't that crazy she was just like kind
of mean it's not a crime yeah to be a
diva
that's really sad it is really sad and I
feel like
when the word diva is thrown around
about someone it's like
everyone just sort of believed it I
don't even know if we had it's like the
worst thing you could say about someone
yeah a woman yeah and I don't know if at
the time there were specific instances
of Diva like Behavior but then it was
also coupled like with this tweet where
she's yeah ungrateful and it's like for
those reasons she deserves the mob right
in hindsight it's like
no chill no and you know what it reminds
me of
I kind of love Mariah Carey for that for
like embracing the diva she's like yeah
no I won't walk into a room that isn't
playing my music and I want my water at
64 degrees like she totally Embraces
that as like a positive thing and did
you see the drama when she was on Meghan
markle's podcast what's the drama so she
was like talking about the word Diva and
she was like you're a diva honey and
Megan was like what to clutching her
cross no I'm not and then you know how
Megan's podcast is like interview style
but then Megan will like draw out and do
like a narration
and she was like I couldn't believe that
Mariah called me a diva it's like you're
literally a princess relax like Diva's
not a big deal and Mariah's like really
out here destigmatizing the word like it
should be like yeah we're all Divas we
should be Divas
women who need you know only the green M
M's like it's fabulous totally what's
wrong with wrong with that I so agree I
want to read constance's book I imagine
she's very misunderstood yeah and I'm
interested in hearing her story so and a
book is a fabulous way to become
understood yeah but it requires people's
time patience and people have to be open
to one to understand you I'm open I'm
very open
and to get so famous so fast when you're
young like we're human like that's what
happens people become at a little out of
control as long as they don't murder
anyone I'm okay right like we need
perspective like as a society and
sometimes I even for us I feel like that
perspective doesn't come until it's too
late if time passes and you look back on
something that felt like the biggest
deal and it's like what were we all bent
out of shape over no every time moving
forward where we're discussing someone
getting backlash or going through some
sort of cancellation we need to have a
perspective oh meter like you need to
say in the grand scheme of the world The
Big Bang Theory what does this mean what
does this represent what does this
symbolize a hundred percent our fifth
and final story is actually someone
who's getting some backlash so I wonder
if you'll bring that today okay let's
see I'll use the Big Bang Theory
the try guys will edit Ned Fulmer out of
future videos amid shocking infidelity
Scandal so
the try guys put out a video called what
happened and the remaining guys of try
opened up about the future of the try
guys they said quote Ned Fulmer is no
longer working with the try guys by now
we're assuming you've seen the Reddit
threads and tick tocks and tweets and
news articles we want to give you a
timeline of what's transpired and some
transparency into our decision making
throughout this video there will be
things that we want to say or go into
further but as I'm sure you're aware
there's some legal issues we have to
consider as we go through everything
then Keith explained that in the turn of
events begin begin after multiple fans
saw Fulmer and a colleague engaging in
public romantic behavior on Labor Day
weekend after asking Ned about it he
confirmed the affair had been secretly
happening for a while
Keith said it was obviously very
shocking to us we just want you to know
that we had no idea this was going on
all of that information was just as
shocking to all of us as this has been
for you this week then
um Lee Yang explained that a three-week
investigation then began involving
lawyers publicists and Human Resources
experts to oversee the process sounds
like they totally handled it like super
professionally
um sounds like Ned agreed like it
doesn't seem like there's major like
contentiousness here
um and I feel like I said this when we
reported on it first last week like
cheating on your wife terrible but if
you work at Google and you cheat on your
wife uh you still get to work
with someone who works for you
no for you oh yeah I forgot that that's
what makes it like a fireball offense
right
yeah and people were saying in the
comments when we did talk about this
that Ned's like whole personality not
that was his marriage less or of a crime
but his whole personality on the show
was his marriage so I think that just
makes it a bigger deal to the face no
and it feels deceptive invested it feels
deceptive when you're following someone
that would be like if this whole time I
was eating salads you know right right
you're following someone who's a liar
yeah like putting out one thing and
being another yeah and that's the thing
with white internet personalities who
get canceled or go through Scandal
always feel like bigger is because this
relationship you form as a viewer of a
digital personality is much deeper than
that of a traditional celebrity because
you're like obsessed you're seeing this
this person in their bathtub you're
seeing them like at so many there's so
much more of a connection they're so
much more vulnerable and that's why it
can be bigger you feel like you know
them and so it feels like someone that
you know imagine if you found out a
close friend was cheating on their wife
it'd be the biggest right meanwhile and
that's why it's really important to like
remember that as much as you love an
influencer or a podcast or even you
don't know them like you don't know them
and so when they do something that you
know
doesn't align with the version that you
have of them in your head like you can't
get to a bent out of shape because at
the end of the day you don't know this
person like for real yeah like I don't
of course you can disagree with him
cheating on his wife especially with an
employee but like you don't have to like
deconstruct your entire self I think a
lot of times why internet culture is a
little toxic is because
the level of obsession people have with
like certain YouTubers or even tick
tockers they build their sense of self
around Addison Ray yeah and it's not
healthy it's and I think it's really
much worse with like younger kids I
think the older you get you can separate
oh this is a podcast or something I like
to watch and this is real life
um but with the younger kids like so
much of their identity and their sense
of self is built around being obsessed
with Charlie demilio yeah and it's not
normal it's not healthy yeah when
Charlie does something that you don't
think Charlie should be doing you have a
crisis uh identity crisis yeah
you need to separate for real it's not
healthy at all like you need to separate
even I feel like
you know years ago when we were in our
most like toxic ERA with a lot of our
fans like when we said or did something
that people didn't like the way that
people reacted was so abnormal because
like the level that they were obsessed
with the show was also sorry it was
abnormal yeah you you really need to and
that's what's so weird about the
internet because I don't think this
happens with traditional celebrities
like I don't think you become so
obsessed with like Shawn Mendes honestly
I don't think maybe Shawn Mendes okay
you don't become so obsessed with Julie
Bowen right when she does something you
disagree with it shakes you to your core
yeah and I'm not I'm sure this is a
crisis I wasn't saying what I said about
the toes like to be rude like of course
you should be obsessed with this show
it's amazing but like I think you know
we got to a place where you know
the obsession
takes on an unhealthy level of
obsession
yeah and so when of course no one is
ever gonna
talk and say and act in the exact way
you want them to we're all different
human beings we're all extremely nuanced
so it's inevitable that someone you are
obsessed with will do something or say
something or make a decision that you
don't love and if you react in a really
unhinged way it's probably because your
obsession was a little unhinged
perhaps or you just can't handle
difference of opinions difference of
opinion or like something happening that
you don't agree with yeah
I just think internet culture is really
slippery
and it's really
um it can become like extremely
unhealthy and toxic
yeah so so best of luck to the try guys
who went from four to three everyone's
rebranding everyone's rebranding
um quickly because we don't have an
official TV recap today but I know you
caught up on tell me lies and I'm all
caught up as well and there's a new
episode dropping tomorrow oh my God so
tell me your thoughts the girlies just
got back from winter break Steven is
more unhinged and manipulative than ever
I was literally like
queasy watching this episode like when
he was in the sauna with yeah that was
sick my stomach was like in knots he's
so sick and so Twisted why the [ __ ] does
he care he's like an actual sociopath
um my prediction remembering that this
is a book and so there's going to be
like an end now I have to start to think
of like the end game and I do think that
maybe and maybe this is a spoiler but I
think that he killed Macy I don't think
that what he said was the truth I think
he doesn't want anyone to know about
Drew because then they'll go back and
investigate and not that I know that
Steven was in the car who cares yeah
that you know there was more to look
into about it so that's just like I
agree yeah because I wasn't sure if he
actually was in the car and he was being
genuine in that moment because I'm like
that that kind of doesn't add up no I
think he was it was a half truth and it
was enough of the story to make Lucy
feel like connected to him right and to
move on from being upset but that's not
the whole story because he's a big fat
liar it's also so painful to watch Lucy
who's like in this vulnerable position
like she's a freshman in college she's
obsessed with this guy like she's so
vulnerable and to see her just be so
manipulated because we're like watching
from an outside perspective so it's like
come on Lucy wake up but it's like she's
in it and
it's so painful to watch her
um just slide down this slippery slope
because he's so controlling and
manipulative and he knows how much she
likes him and how how how to manipulate
her because she's so young and
impressionable it's very it's painful to
watch it's painful to watch I'm happy
that Diana inadvertently is out of the
equation now because like Lucy she
deserves better and I love that um the
people who are getting married in real
time are like starting to find one
another like they're just now connecting
like I love that girl I love that girl I
need them to find each other sooner I
need him to stop talking to Lucy he said
he tried to help it's time to go but
like when you're I think he likes Lucy
he does he said so and so that's awkward
yeah
yeah but like it isn't it isn't because
like I'm sure there are plenty of
college relationships where it's like oh
actually at one point yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah Everyone likes each other in
college for a minute yeah like I went to
college with Cole Sprouse he was
obsessed with me he was obsessed with
mclartia but could you blame him I went
to school actually with Dylan and Cole
they were just like two years older than
me that's why they didn't talk for years
yeah no 100 like I actually I went to
Argo T and I saw coal and that's where
we first met and he was just like kind
of like all over me it was like a little
embarrassing
um no actually going to NYU at the same
time that Dylan and Cole did like
everyone was talking about them all the
time it was like kind of crazy
yeah they hadn't had their Resurgence
yet so they were just the kids from
Suite Life and it was like you know what
go good for them going to college trying
to be normal Dylan had a girlfriend all
throughout College Cole was like the
more mysterious one he was like an
archeology major
um it was it was really cool
that's pretty I also went to college the
same time as Anna Sophia Robb she was
also at NYU
that was before Carrie Diaries yes after
Bridge to Terabithia you weren't
obsessed like no but I saw her and like
I would Quake that was like the cool
there was like very few things that were
cool about NYU but one cool thing was
like a lot of celebrities went not for
all four years but like Carly Kloss was
there for a short period of time it was
cool
what celebrities now are go to school at
NYU they're obviously a lot younger than
us but I feel like there's always a
celeb or two yeah because we always get
like the news I don't know
that's a good question I feel like a lot
of like tick tockers
like when I was popping off on like
Instagram and like my blogger days and I
was an NYU student like nobody cared
well because everyone in in at NYU is
working on their art yes yes I was just
wondering artists it was really like an
artist Collective
um so those are the fast five stories
that was the toast and that's all we got
for you guys right that is all she wrote
We will see you on Thursday because
tomorrow we will be fasting oh yeah what
are you gonna read so I'm still reading
city of likes and I'm gonna download one
other book I'm not sure I have so many
on my list have you heard of woman on
fire no what's that so that is the book
that the book club decided to move
forward with after after I threw it
after you and everyone like really
appreciated your
candor
so here's what the uh
let me look up book club that's what the
decision was made to go with woman on
fire it's this looks great about art
thievery and Nazis looks great I did say
like come on guys Nazis for our first
book like can't we do a little porn but
it's about time I expand my horizons
yeah and that's what a book club is for
you can read the book on your own time
100
and I would feel like a little
embarrassed reading like some spicy
books and then like having to talk to my
friends about it you know yeah that's
personal stuff it's personal let
something spark discussion porn is more
personal than comedy
all right that's our show everyone who
is celebrating Yom Kippur tomorrow have
a very easy fast
make it meaningful make it meaningful
we'll see you on the other side if
you're not celebrating well not
celebrating if you're not observing this
holiday tomorrow have a great hump day
um I'm jealous of you
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the past Tech stories that you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available to podcast anywhere
podcast can be found out Spotify iTunes
Stitch or public video I got rid of
castbox all the places we'll be losing a
podcast find us more in Chelsea faster
review about a beautiful setting of
smart we are hope you guys have been in
Tuesday and we'll see you on Thursday
for our final show of the week bye bye